Yeah.
Um,
so we were talking about this Elsa gate thing.
Yes,
this is,
this is weird.
Now this is not a conspiracy theory ladies and gentlemen.
So before you go,
oh,
I can't believe you show,
here's the merch.
So it's your turn to stolen.
Listen,
there's something going on where they're making these youtube clips and they
play like,
you know,
how have you watch,
if you watch a youtube clip,
say on the brand new 2019 corvette Zr one like I'm a,
I'm a car freak.
I love watching those videos.
Like wow,
look how fast.
Look at it.
Go what a beast.
And if you just let that play ill,
youtube will suggest a another corvette movie or video and play that and maybe a
video on a shootout between a couple of different types of cars.
He would handles better.
And then you'll just keep playing like car videos cause it thinks you're on that
loop will somewhere along the line,
if you're on a kid's loop,
you can get looped into one of these Elsa gate videos.
Now,
some of them,
like the one Brian showing me,
he's like really shitty CGI second life and it's like these cartoon characters
get together and they become like sexualized and they drink sometimes and the
babies keep getting their heads busted open.
Like the babies fall and the beer bottle flies through the air and hits the baby
in the head and cuts the baby's head open and blood's all over the place and
that one happens all the time.
It repeats itself over and over and over again.
That same scene in a bunch of different weird cartoons with like babies and baby
animals and you know there's anthropomorphization videos where it's like,
you know the,
the,
the wolf has a bunch of pigs with them and shit and the pigs get drunk like that
kind of shit.
But there's like hundreds and hundreds of them and youtube is me.
They had to be alerted to this stuff.
You know,
people were watching them with their kid and it would go on auto play and your
one year old is also in watching a beer bottle,
fly through the hair and head in a three,
five to the eight rather and bash a baby on the head and cause a big Gash.
Have you seen any of those?
I've seen,
yeah.
I just,
cause I used to watch the ones that you,
you know the second life ones where it's just ridiculous.
Like this stuff is crazy.
It's weird.
I didn't even know about this.
They dress up in these cartoons.
They have little babies that are dressed up like Spiderman or like Elsa and like
this,
this scene keeps happening over and over again where they have beer,
they get fucked up and then as the baby falls,
the beer bottle bounces off his head and shatters and lands on the ground and
the baby's bleeding.
It happens over and over again.
And so in this one with the minions,
a little baby minions,
they fall,
Bam gets caught in the head.
It's the same scene.
Here's the Mickey Mouse.
One little babies get fucked up.
They fall beer bottle hits the baby in the head is another one with a little
foxes.
They get fucked up.
Beer bottle hits the kid in the head.
It's always the same shit.
It's a stupid,
it's not just stupid.
It's weird.
It's weird because it's not,
it's not just things happen and it's the same violence scene over and over again
and the babies are the ones that are getting brutalized in the,
is it getting hit in the head with beer bottles?
Giant Gash,
his blood like what is that?
Yeah,
it's almost like that.
What's that?
Yeah,
the youtube crap or that you just to be really popular where they would just
edit things together real fast and an end with like like screaming and what was
that?
But that was user created.
That was a bunch of people like you could see those people doing that.
They just decided to try to talk real fast and cut out all the breaths in
between it and slam it together.
Look,
you have no attention span whatsoever.
Now this stuff like in what we're watching now,
I find,
I feel like they're all,
they're all using the same characters,
right?
So it seems like to me it's from a message board.
It's like when we were back in the day on your message board and we would like
make all these videos and stuff like that.
It seems like it's from a group of people that all are doing it,
you know,
collectively like to me it seems like,
like you'll find like a deep four Chan thread in it or something where like,
oh,
I did the baby falling video or something.
No,
there's a bunch of different ones man.
I mean there's,
there's this was like with real people,
but the ones that you're talking about with the,
the cartoon ones,
they're being made in other countries.
They're not speaking English in any of them.
It's all like noises and stuff.
And um,
they're generating like if their ad friendly and some of them were approved for
ads,
they're generating a tremendous amount of money.
You gotta think about how many hits these fucking things are getting and how
many like see if you could pull up one and see how many millions of hits it had.
Yeah,
I just pulled up,
had 5 million,
5 million.
Okay,
so 5 million hits is the business.
All right?
If you've got ads on a video for little kids,
that gets 5 million hits,
that's a business.
Now if you've got those things in there,
generating them by computers,
so you're making hundreds and hundreds of them and you put them all over the
Internet and they all have 5 million hits each.
You're talking about a substantial amount of money that you're getting every
month and they're just making these things.
And then the real fucked up thing is like,
apparently there's some,
again,
I just read the beginning of this and then never read any further into it,
but read it.
Uh,
had a thread apparently where these people were trying to decipher some of the
things that are being said and the comments and they think that they're using
the comments as like ways we're child trafficking.
People can communicate with Jenna.
This is like speculation,
which sounds like wow,
that seems far fetched.
But doesn't child trafficking sound far fetched?
I mean,
you know it's real,
right?
Child trafficking sounds crazy farfetched.
Like the idea that someone so evil that they're selling children,
right?
Doesn't it?
Well that doesn't it?
Yeah.
So if that is,
then why wouldn't it be that they would communicate?
I mean is it more far fetched that they communicate in code in some sort of way
in the comments?
Yeah,
because they probably wouldn't do it on kid videos would probably do it like
just like any video,
like tractor.
It could be videos or something.
I think.
Yeah,
it could be.
Maybe they're not that smart.
That's where the trauma Lester's,
right.
But,
but also that like these why these kids are not going to make comments.
So making comments on
these videos.
It to me,
again,
I,
it seems like it's a,
it's a group of people somewhere and it's making these now the fact that that
youtube is letting them sell it as kids,
they need to change.
Youtube needs to change how they have kid videos.
Cat Videos should have a team of people.
You get approved,
then you become an for sure two kits.
That's it.
You can't just upload anything and put the kid to tag on it.
You should not be allowed to have the kid tag kids find out about it.
Yeah.
You give your kid the user response when you give your kid like the iPad and he
put it on Youtube.
Kids that should be selected videos only.
It's been approved by eyeballs and so on it.
I should not be able to make a kid video.
You know?
That's true and definitely not be able to make kid video where a kid gets hit in
the head with a fucking bottle right now.
If that shit was like just on a,
like once someone,
one of us did it and were like,
I just made all these stupid videos of kids falling down on the ground and it
wasn't for kids,
and then you'll be like,
that's just a stupid cartoon that you see on like adult swim or something like
that.
Right.
Four in the morning,
right in there.
You could see something like that on adult swim at four o'clock in the morning,
especially the ones that I have watched,
those stupid ones that could actually be like some sort of a,
an like some thing that,
what's that called?
What's interspliced inside of a show where like a non sequitur video comes in
and what's that called?
It's like an adult swim cartoon where you're like,
what the or a commercial or a commercial?
I don't know where.
That's just,
it just gets stuck in there where the Mickey Mouse Daddy is drinking with the
babies.
The babies fall and gets hit in the head with a bottle.
Like what the fuck?
And then you cut to some wolf that's telling you about the past and they're
like,
robot chicken a lot.
Just to real quick set team second thing and be like,
what?
What's that?
What does the word interstition what does that word?
I don't know.
There's,
I know you're talking about it's blank interstitial.
Is that it?